hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play SCP
containment breach now we just got out
of the sewers which proved to be a bit
of a son of a [ __ ] wait where am i
anyway ok yeah and we just went to this
place where we could go into another
maintenance tunnel which i think is
different from the actual sewers were
what that other sdp was contained I
don't really know I don't want to go
down there again I don't know why I
don't know why in the world I don't want
to go down there again
but just as a personal preference I
would prefer not to okay so anyway we
got the pill from that guy and
apparently we still have it and I don't
know if that had a battery in it
they apparently proved they improve this
so that this moves as you move well I
haven't been down here yet I don't think
so I do like the improvements that they
have made in this game because it feels
like I'm getting less lost and less run
in circles because before you know that
it kind of let you go into little
circles okay if I go in there I'd summon
radical Larry which I do not want to do
I'm pretty sure that's what that does
anyway
this is uh oh crap
uh huh nope nope not happening no how
did he get out I don't care
[ __ ] no
all those sounds I hate those towns what
is this
shop okay I don't want to go in there
the windows get covered with losing
blood which is always fantastic thank
you so much oh I think I have to go in
there which I don't want to do I hate
that guy so much I hate him as a giant
dick seems to be locked
okay that's a good sign if that means
that I don't have to go in there now or
maybe it'll open up in a second I don't
know is he in there is he in there is he
in there I think I see him I think I see
a little bit of oh hi can't see your
face okay so this door is obviously not
opening which is great great I don't
want to go in there anyway so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna have to go down
into the maintenance tunnel but you guys
are going to love cuz I love the
maintenance tunnel
okay here we go
stop being a big baby and get down in
there get down in the hole
get down in the hole oh I hear water
okay nevermind ah crap I can't move my
mouse oh what's going on here
why is radical arey coming out of the
walls right now why right now
Oh oh crap
is that good it's not a good thing it's
not a good thing not a good thing God
that I got that oh let me up where do we
go oh crap oh no oh no oh wait no no no
yes yes coming up Oh what what there's
no button dad put it up wanna die okay
ah everybody's in bed Newars oh my god
okay where do I go what do I do hold on
what do I go what do I do
we have so much running juice I only
have so much come on bring it on radical
[ __ ] radical douche here we go
this is something no that is what
where's the dingdong Dave what is that
why is that a pool of blood
why are these elevators here and they
don't work why is our pool blood there I
don't know I don't have time
radical areas in hot pursuit oh my god
God where did one where did 173 come
from where did he come from
what the hell ah oh oh yeah goddamn it
him out of nowhere I don't know how he
does that he just gets down into the
sewers and all sudden BOPE he's he's
decides to say hi for some stupid reason
oh and oh oh the bad one but that was a
good one good scare good job there won
7-3 you did your job so I literally have
no other to go than down here so I guess
I just gotta suck it up and get gone
where I swear one seven three comes out
of the walls just randomly he just
appears for no reason and he appears
behind me which is totally douchey take
two of this horrible adventure into the
sewers which I hate oh the door just
flashes open of course ah balls right
off the bat don't have no time okay so I
just got to keep going okay hey I want
to save but at the same time I don't
want to save but at the same time I
really don't I don't know if I save if
I'll become super trapped here
hi hey how's it going buddy how's it
going friend okay let's get to this
corner Inlet safe okay
we saved we're in it we're committed
you're won 7-3 snaps my neck I'll be
able to start again oh crap
where is he exit don't tell me where is
it
Oh why are you downer how'd you get that
er oh hi hey where'd you go I don't hear
you anymore I want to know where the
hell am I getting out of here
I probably shouldn't be walking
backwards through these halls well
that's the best option I got right now
so don't judge me Oh Oh over here hang
on I can't close the door just walking
blind into what I'll be walking it dude
oh is this a dead end oh no oh no oh no
I really did it ah what is it what I get
what I already have that I don't need
that what do I need that I don't need
that
what I get that you gave that to me
above where am I for the hell am i I
don't know where I am I don't think
there's anything by me I don't think
there's like a door or anything yeah
what was the point of that
oh don't do that to me don't do that to
me you douche
oh okay going around you okay we're just
gonna have a little friendly you never
see each other party we're gonna play a
game of hide and seek and I'm gonna
leave you in the bushes just like all my
friends left me but this is the only
other elevator but it no work it don't
work okay I think there's only one way
out I'm gonna have to try to noclip so
what was the console yeah there we go
I'm gonna try to noclip on and then I'm
gonna try to go straight up great ah
crap there's nothing there what is that
thing there ah nope nothing there's
nothing there well I know nothing how
can there be nothing there's nothing
there's absolutely nothing
damn it oh damn it goddammit I gotta
load the game again okay
back in the game why am I here wait what
what oh come on
you can't be serious what the hell
suddenly the door hey it works
hey there we go alright good hi oh no
way is this where we were before I don't
know I don't care I'm out yeah it's
different alright that worked alright I
don't know why but it worked
Oh nope
now go down to helmet more than any
other game I gotta say the ambience
yeah I'm beyond aah same thing all right
you know what I'll go down this ironical
Larry how you doing you doing good
look good good good friend oh boy
another one a series of tubes easy - al
what ba whoa what what is going on
what's huh you're an alarm blaring but
wha what what is happening what the
world what what you gotta be joking me
it the wall closed off
no clip off oh I don't even understand
there might be some bugs with the most
recent update I have no idea
this is carry on
okay the Omega warhead silo but I don't
know if my key card is enough to open
this no I need a I need a higher level
key card apparently what hi hey how's it
going buddy hey you doing I made a
statue of you during my charity
livestream you look really good and by
really good I mean you look like ass
awful don't don't do it what is this
what is that oh the computer ah let's go
talk hi
Hey okay you need it you need to dip
this network ah come on okay goodbye
blink oh nope
what what is he doing is he doing is he
not gonna is he not gonna come over here
does he not wanna oh he does
okay I thought you didn't want to play
with the computer guy for a second there
but it barely verbally okay with it
he was just thinking about it real hard
don't you I don't want it go away
forever and die in a fire
if die in ten fires for all I care die
in a hundred and fifty fires really oh
you know like this game ah not like this
oh I really like this game good game
this game is a good game
I'll have another another okay all right
another series of tubes where's this
gonna lead ok this leads to radical
Larry's area but um I don't think I've
even have I summoned him yet did that
count wanna what is this whoa what whoa
what is this what is this it's new what
is this what what the hell is this
cowbell ah jeez got to get more cowbell
gotta get more cowbell got it mean
business five one three I don't think
I've seen this one this must be one of
the new ones hey read it okay supposed
to be 1 cubic meter block of gelatin
what 5 on 3 is Oh cement suspended okay
the gelatin I gotta read this is
Christopher Walken I got a fever and the
only prescription is more cowbell
any noise okay I don't know all right
and let me save try it out bing-bong
bing-bong anybody bring out your dead
bring out two dead anybody no one only
gonna bring two dead no one's gonna
bring out your dead
I'm sitting here asking for your dad and
I got a fever only prescription Bing
bong
okay I don't know what it do but what
what is that what is that that's know
what it's gone it disappeared it
disappeared where'd he go
it was there oh how about know about no
how about a million of nope how about
10,000 nope how about a whole bunch of
nope we're gonna do that we're gonna do
no I'm gonna go with no fur gonna go
with
now it's down to me crapping my pants
how's it sounding me filling up my
shorts where am I going
what am i doing oh my god what am i
doing
where am I going oh I see okay I didn't
know for a second there oh my god this
bad this bad is bad news bad do we take
off my mask
what does they have to be oh oh oh I see
you want to play hey SCP f [ __ ]
specie f [ __ ] you want to play with
good friend over it oh crap
we can't get around you I can't get
around - I can't get around
oh no cuz it up you son of a [ __ ] I
hate you don't know what the cowbell
does but maybe it's a sub maybe it's
summons one seven three to me Bing bong
Bing bong Bing bong what happened here
anyway I'm gonna go back because I don't
want to go four one seven three
something about a block of gelatin
something bashed down this door like
seriously and stop the gelatin I guess
the gelatin is made to stop it ring was
this
let's stay nope God in heaven hell I
think the wall cracked floor ceiling I
haven't been up top in 12 years I don't
know which edge is top when the locks
drop the security wall is released each
subsection is sealed now cut off blah
blah opposed to be secured in the sector
but the item overloaded bugger the usual
assignments I can't imagine what primary
storage sections are like I saw a crunk
creep wall bulge I mean bulge like a
bedsheet with a naughty child underneath
who then just go back down my teeth are
feeling on what someone is going insane
that much is obvious
Bing bong bring out your dad family
nobody nobody is gonna say hi to me all
right they want me to go no wait this
cycle is through to the other one you're
not gonna fool me this goes from one to
the other you can't fool you can't fool
me bro can't fool me bro I know what you
do I know what games you're playing bud
dad don't even try to fool me I know I
know your tricks I know all your tricks
you're not gonna get me you're not gonna
get me I know you're here is where you
is I know and you're right there
yep close close we'll go this way then
we're gonna go around go take this off
this is it here we go so we're good
we're definitely good here where am I
now what lovely place mi here oh this is
the virus the zombie virus ah okay let
me see if I can open it let me see if I
can over this nope can't open them I
don't have good enough I'm only a level
three this is where six to eight or six
seven three or whatever the name is was
stored but I think I am all out of time
officially all out of time for this part
so this is getting pretty interesting I
don't know what the cowbell does but my
mom bang bang
I could probably read but I'd rather it
be a surprise hey mom
okay so anyway I rang it so anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
you see what's down here first
without a real cat or one is that real
kid look like a quiz
which are the masks